water is the liquid of life as vital as
the air you breathe nowadays most of us
Fetch and carry no more water is
delivered to us where we need it
whenever we want it turn a faucet and
there is water at any hour of the day or
night water Blue Gold without water life
cannot survive tonight we asked the
tough questions what would happen if it
turned on the faucet and nothing came
out you don't think that could happen
think again terrorism some say a tiny
amount of bioagent could contaminate an
entire city what is our government doing
to protect our most precious resource
what about the water that comes out of
your F did you know that there could be
stuff in there that could harm or even
kill your kids we're going to test for
that tonight and what about our liberal
tree hugging Democrats what are they
doing to ensure our crops are getting
the essential water they need water that
will produce the food that we eat in
Central Valley California water is being
diverted away from Farmers so the
environmentalists can protect the 3in
fish this is a case of fish over people
is it and an OMG moment we're
questioning whether our short-sighted
political leaders are selling our water
right out from under us to close budget
gaps even foreigners have been tapping
our water disgraceful Brazen and in some
cases downright
corrupt in the year 2001 35 billion
dollar worth of bottled water was
consumed worldwide today bottled water
costs more per gallon than gasoline we
my friends are the new Oil Barons okay
that was Hollywood let's talk reality
now how vulnerable is America's water
supply is our most precious commodity
being protected are we vulnerable to
terrorist attacks that could literally
our usable water let's bring in
CBN terrorism analyst Eric stle back Pam
Geller from Atlas shrug. comom and Fox
medical contributor Dr Mark seagull I'm
going to start with you Eric you've
reported on this possibly I guess a biot
terror threat before Is that real is
there a possibility of that well look
with the water supply Eric which we're
talking about Al-Qaeda has been talking
about this for years now there have been
documents uncovered in Afghanistan in
Pakistan that point to Al-Qaeda wanting
to hit our water supply here in the US
and in Great Britain here's the big
question is this feasible can it happen
on a large scale Eric in terms of
contaminating say a reservoir with a
biological agent that's going to be
tricky that'll be very difficult it
would take a lot of time it would take
take a lot of effort it would draw a lot
of attention but on a smaller scale say
on a community level say affecting the
water supply in an individual building
that could happen and if they're able to
get an agent inside say a water
treatment plant or a reservoir just like
we had an Al-Qaeda agent just a few
months ago Eric it was revealed working
inside nuclear power plants in New
Jersey Maryland Pennsylvania if you get
an Al-Qaeda mole a Jihadi mole inside a
water treatment plant all bets are off
okay hang on hang on a second Erica Pam
um I think this is real I spent some
time and some water filtration plants we
even hear that the there's an access to
our water supply through our fire
hydrants yes there is actually there
were arrests made a few years ago in
Denver of terrorists who had
documentation to use microbiology agents
to poison the water we also know that
alqaeda warned a london-based news
magazine that they were targeting our
water supply 15 % of our water structure
Services 75% of the people and the
balance as Eric was saying are the
smaller communities the bottom line is
all they have to do is maybe bomb a dam
and the catastrophic flooding and the
loss of life would devastate the country
interesting interesting angle not not
actually a biot terrorist attack to the
water but just uh flooding a community
let me go to Dr seagull doc what are we
looking at if if there were an agent
that were that were able that they were
able to put into our water supply and we
drank it what could happen Eric I'm very
concerned about this there's 100,000 of
these plants that are actually below the
radar and if it gets to into a finished
water uh unit it could get right to the
faucet without you even be able to
detect it some of these agents could
cause massive diarrhea like Cera
cryptosporidia chlorine might have some
effect on that but something like
Anthrax can live for 2 years in the
water supply in Spore form without it
being eradicated by the chlorine and we
get Anthrax and then fear takes over as
a pathogen if a few people get sick with
Anthrax or die it can be uniformally
fatal everyone is going to panic and and
Doc not only not only these agents but
other things like
bacteria um salmonella right absolutely
and the plague Eric has never been
tested in this way we're worried about
Bubonic plague being used in the water
supply and chalera which is another
bacteria you know you can treat that if
you're looking for it but Physicians are
not trained these days to look for Cola
it could then spread out into the
community Eric what do you think about
that uh are we are we being alarmist or
is this potentially a real threat well
no Eric I think it's a genuine threat
look if Al-Qaeda is talking about it and
talking about it consistently I might
add as Pam mentioned it's a real threat
another thing if Al-Qaeda say targets uh
a treatment center or you know fly an
airplane into uh a reservoir into a
water man here's another strategy and if
we're talking about Eric you know
they're thinking about it the bad guys
cut off the water supply to a community
and then set fires in that Community
you'll have no way to put these fires
out they would rage there'd be no water
supply in those communities Al-Qaeda has
talked about using tactics like this
that don't involve biological agents Pam
I'm bring in the panel in a second but
go ahead Pam the big problem is the lack
of security at these facilities
particularly the 75% of the water
structure that Services the small
communities and while it may seem like a
not a big deal if they sabotage a town
that has 10,000 people what it would
cause economically impact and also the
the public confidence would be
completely undermined it would be a
disaster all right hang in there Eric
Pam and Dr sigle don't go away I want to
bring in today's special panel Nicholas
de benedicta CEO of Aqua America good
friend of mine for a long time sir
thanks for joining us Howard gold clean
economy investor and Lyn Tilton CEO CEO
of patriarch Partners Nick I'm going to
go right to you sir you are the guy in
the front line of the water what are you
doing to protect their water supply well
I think Pamela's point is very well
taken in the big cities we have all
kinds of security we all have have all
kinds of expenditures Millions just for
our company has been spent the FBI
Homeland Security directs us but there
are 50,000 Water Supplies in the country
now whether a terrorist would want news
in you know small town of Iowa versus
New York City is a different story too
but uh probably they're more do you have
someone looking for this for I'm not
just talking about you know putting
guards at your Gates cuz I've seen the
guards at the gates of of various Water
Supplies around the country I'm talking
about people really with intelligence uh
working with the intelligence Community
to find out if any of these plots are
planned most most of the security we
have is electronic monitoring uh
checking water supply coming into the
plant obviously going out of the plant
uh motion detection cameras cameras all
over we could spot somebody who's in the
parking lot uh 2 in the morning
centrally uh go ahead Howard um where do
you stand on this are you concerned
about it yeah certainly it's a concern I
mean you know as decanalization plans
come online across the globe they're
going to be absolutely Target uh
terrorist targets so you know how do you
how do you account for that is you know
it's how do you account for them blowing
up anything I mean obviously these are
going to be hard targets that they're
looking for you know I think the only
option is is to look at you know
Distributing water in other ways and and
there are kind of new technologies out
there talking about Mega water sheds
multi-point Source water um things like
that but it's still early days for
what do you think Lenny are you are you
looking into this you're an investor you
see a lot of businesses come and go um
what about the water I mean I got to
think it's a there's a lot of risk to
that look I think I think water is is
the number one commodity in the world
and we know there's a shortage and you
know without it we can't live and so
we've been very involved in water greenw
you know systems as well as armored
vehicles to protect water um and we make
Motors and drives that do desalination
plants and move water only 1% of the the
world Supply you bringing up a very good
point Lenny though is is that where the
investment of the future is is to
protect the water supply or is it like
Howard says come up with new ways of of
uh I guess cleaning the water
desalinized the water I think it's all
things I think you have to protect it
first of all I think you do have to find
new green ways of uh you know making
water clean I think you have to move
water around the world which takes you
know the movement you need desalination
plans for people who you know live on
salt surrounded by salt water but water
is the most precious commodity and need
it hey uh Pam can we protect the water
supply I mean it's so vast no uh the
infrastructure the water infrastructure
is impossible to protect and I think
it's the wrong approach it's this hiding
under the desk waiting for the next
attack clearly you have to secure the
borders we know that Hezbollah is using
the Narco Transit borders in Mexico we
have to know who's coming into this
country I just don't think this
defensive position this crouching in a
fetal position is the way to address the
the mortal enemy go ahead Eric is there
a way to secure our water supply no the
short answer is no and let's not forget
at the end of the day guys this is
psychological terrorism we mentioned New
York City or Iowa okay contaminate the
water supply in New York or contaminate
it in a small town in Iowa I would argue
that if you contaminate the water supply
in some small middle American
communities that's a pretty effective
strategy for the terrorist because of
the psychological the paranoia it
creates and Al is moving to these
smaller scale type attacks do Dr seagull
let me ask you this is there any way to
protect ourselves I mean remember I
remember the anthrax scares that were
going on after 911 um what was that the
um the the the drug we were all supposed
to stock up on cpro righto right will
that work is that helpful that's helpful
but but let's face it if you actually
get sick with one of these things it's
going to be very very hard to catch up
Eric I think of everything that's been
said the biggest defense is actually the
larger plants I mean it's ironic that
the that the biot terrorism Act of 2002
only protects water supplies for more
than 3,300 people but the reality is
that over 100,000 treatment plants in
the United States are for the small
communities that's where we're going to
see the attack treatment plants sir what
what about it Nick I mean you're you're
you you operate reservoirs right is that
right uh the bigger companies in the
bigger areas have reservoirs have large
uh filtration plants uh New York doesn't
by the way New York is doesn't filter
their water but the uh small towns
usually use Wells so it's harder to
contaminate a well but I would say
they're not as sophisticated in their
treatment Andor their security all right
Eric stle back we're going to say thank
you to you a little 3-in fish called the
Delta smelt has slithered its way onto
the endangered species list in Central
Valley California and the federal court
has closed off water pumps to the
farmers that irrigate their fields is
Congress really choosing fish over
people up next on the Fox Business
Network the power to to prosper by 2025
1.8 billion people will live in
countries or regions with absolute water
scarcity this means the world water wars
will officially be on so is America's
blue gold at risk of being completely
drained by foreign countries Pam Geller
pad AA representative Nunes and Dr Peter
Glick and the panel are back to weigh in
uh where am I going to start here Pam
you say it's okay go ahead sell our
water which frankly I'm surprised you
say that why I'm a free maret Advocate
you're obviously a mixed economy kind of
a guy very dangerous slipp here's the
thing here's the thing if you're a
company and you develop a new techn a
new pen great sell it I don't care your
private Company sell it we have one body
of water in this country in the world
really why would we sell such a precious
resource many of these companies are
privately owned they should be free to
sell the water there are new
technologies being developed in Israel
to De salinate water why can't the
market move forward why sell the
technology to salinate the water but
don't sell the darn water what about a
congressman where am I Am I
Wrong well I think you have to look at
in the United States we have a
relatively Safe Water Supply and really
our forefathers in this country
especially in California which is
arguably one of the driest areas we
actually have plenty of water here and
they were smart to build infrastructure
to handle that our problem is the
radical green environmental groups that
want to take the water away and throw it
out to the ocean now there are other
parts of the world like the Middle East
and such that do have water shortages
but but not in the United States okay
what about a radical green Environmental
Group powered what do you think throw it
right in the ocean I've heard from our
poor Farmers the ocean but I mean the
fact is that when we talk about selling
it why not unless we have infrastructure
that we're utilizing that unlike oil and
natural gas and other things this is a
refreshing Source yet we're using it
faster than it can refresh but in areas
there there are there is plenty of water
around there and if people want to sell
it you know let them sell it under heavy
regulatory constraints I know I got Dr
Glick on my side doctor what do you
think I'm right aren't I don't sell our
precious resource sell the technology to
make it
cleaner I think there's a lot of fantasy
going on here the truth is uh water's a
public good water is an economic good uh
the free there is no free market for
water but we're not going to sell our
water overseas because the truth is it
costs too much to Move It from some
panel here that every single one of you
guys who say go ahead sell the darn
water who owns the water go ahead Lenny
who owns the water look usually it's the
IP alties or the states that own the
water is do they own anything or is the
people of the municipalities are the
states that own the water well it it's
always the people I mean that's what it
was supposed to be but the reality is if
we can provide jobs in an area where we
have a replenishing water system where
it can go so long as we don't need it
and we're providing jobs and money to
that state to use but it needs to be
regulated we don't we we're black and
white in this country either it's
government or it's business or either
whether it's you know environmentally
pure great friends are we great friends
yes you're wrong you're absolutely wrong
Congressman I got to ask you this I'm
going to go back to you sir if if the
people of Chicago if mayor Daly gets his
way and he sells access to Lake Michigan
explain to me how the other towns in
municipalities on Lake Michigan on Lake
Michigan should sit by and let the the
water from the lake be sold to India or
somewhere else or Morgan Stanley for
that
matter well look I'm not so sure it's
it's you know actually Peter and I
probably agree on this is probably the
only thing we agree on uh and that is is
that it's pretty hard to move water but
the goal should always be for for the
government leaders both at the federal
state and local levels most importantly
local levels is to figure out how to
provide ample water for their people go
ahead sure you have water I want my guy
who sells water to tell me uh is he
right basic law of physics try and pick
up a fish tank pretty heavy you can't
transport economically water the second
is they doing it Nick tankers to
India other than Texas you just told me
they send tankers over to Fiji to pick
up uh the Fiji Water and they they
bottle it here if they're doing it in
reverse but they're selling it to people
who will pay $2 a pint or whatever not
not to you know third world countries
who owns the water it's a free market as
far as I'm concerned now the money
that's being sold wa can I just can I
just go on a boat in Lake Michigan or or
right off the coast here and go scoop up
a bunch of water and sell it no because
of heavy government controls which I'm
adamantly against my point in all this
is let's say the government was selling
the water who's getting the money do the
people get tax less are they getting
direct checks hey I'm off of that K do
what do you think sir you're a farmer
there do you do don't you have rights to
that
water I think uh and we always say life
and water should not be negotiable water
is a natural Resort that God give us and
here in central B we payt 100% of the
water and we only get in distribute from
Z to 45 or 50 % so water in in life
should not be negotiable Dr
Glick yeah you know if water was only an
economic good representative nunes's
Farmers wouldn't get it it would all go
overseas or it would all go to Industry
what is an economic good but it's also a
public good and we have to balance the
management and the economic and the
public good aspects of it go go ahead
Howard I'm still trying to figure out
why one municipality has rights to water
when it may uh be available or usable to
another well you know I mean to add one
level of difficulty on that too it
depends on where the water is sourced so
where the water what lake that it's
sitting in doesn't necessarily mean that
somebody further Upstream doesn't claim
rights to that water or further
Downstream either so so therefore it has
to be a a kind of national you know
water that's residing yeah but I'm
pretty sure Nicholas when when mayor Dy
sells that water access it's not I'm not
going to see a piece of that profit he
can't do it first of all the Great Lakes
commission which is eight Governor says
you can't divert water out of the Great
Lakes otherwise Arizona would be tapping
it tomorrow although Canada is talking
about pipelining water into the United
States and what about the people who in
in Canada who say they have a right to
the water and who gets that I by this
this is this is CRA what policy is huge
you guys go ahead sir go
ahead we we have an agreement with
Canada to share the Great Lakes if the
are if there was no agreement there
would be this free-for all there would
be this chaos in the world of water but
we have an agreement to share water
between the two countries and it's not
going to be easy for anyone to privatize
that water very good we're going to have
to leave you there Pam Geller and P yala
thank you for being here so if we're
losing water at a furious rate what can
we do about it next some answers to
protect our health and water security so
tell me how's the water filter uh these
are conventional anite coal and sand
filters so these are the filters behind
us and as you're looking down to the
water you're actually looking down what
is this this is the anthy coal layer of
sand sand layer of garnet graded gravel
Stone and this is actually underneath
this is a tile under drain and the
water's drops from top down the water
filters through this bed by gravity down
through and then out into the and all
the sediments get collected in here
collected on top of the anite coal and
then when we back wash the water comes
back up through causes the anite coold
to scrub itself the dirty water goes off
you turn it back off put it back into
surface the water gets filtered
through that was part of my interview
with American Waters manager of quality
water quality Gary Matthews
desalinization I'm sorry desalination is
Big Business and may be the key to the
future of our water supply take a
look in the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia some
might say the most precious commodity is
not oil but a resource many in the world
take for granted water civilization
existed without oil but no civilization
could exist without water in Saudi the
problem of water scarcity is acute the
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia is about the
size of Texas and they have a population
40 million they have no surface water
they have no Rivers they have no Lakes
there were no Rivers under the sand and
the Saudis turned to the Sea instead and
desalination desalination plants can
cost billions to build but the kingdom
has the cash and the energy to fuel them
Americans supplied the original
technology but the Koreans and others
are now big players in the game and all
are learning from the Saudi experience
it's a growth industry by 2025 the UN
predicts 2third of the world's
population will live in areas that are
water stressed there are growing
concerns however about desalination the
fossil fuel it burns the money at costs
and the adverse effects on marine life
researchers like Professor Adel Sharif
are working hard to address the
downsides he believes access to water
will be the greatest challenge of this
Century there might be Wars uh in the
region for example in the Middle East or
elsewhere in the world around water with
97% of the world's water locked up in
oceans there is a massive incentive for
those in the business of desalination to
keep working to get the technology
perfect and that was Fox News Amy Kellog
with the potential for a water shortage
contaminated water and attacks on our
water supply what can we do towards our
future environmentalist Alexandra custo
is back with us along with Pacific
institutes Peter Glick Dr Peter Glick
and representative uh Deon Nunes I'm
sorry guys uh okay Lenny you said you
build these plants it's a big process I
mean
is it is it profitable I mean I hate to
talk about people surviving on Pro with
with profit but what are you doing that
for well we have a company in Italy
called onalo systemi industrial which is
almost 160 years old that actually makes
the motors and the variable drives to
move water and so we we build we provide
them and the automation to build these
but it's essential I mean in in
countries over in the Middle East you
must be able to cleanse and take the
salt out of that water so that there's
drinking water for people so it's
essential that we get the technology
right because it will be so important
for the for the globe for the future of
Clean Water hey Nick I I posed this
question to Gary Matthews at this at the
plant that actually supplies my water I
said how does this work you sell the
water to to the the town I live in and
then the town charges me now does is
this a profit Center for towns oh towns
usually have an Enterprise fund they
usually make money on the water you know
and then balance the police funds and
everything else with it on my water so I
get this monstrous water bill and it's
typically not going directly to Aqua
America or American Water whatever well
we usually own the whole system so in
towns we're in we own it from start to
finish but some towns uh have their own
water systems and they make it a profit
Center oh my goodness all right Howard
what about it D Salin is it a
responsibility to like Lenny Lyn's a
profiteer though but responsibility
absolutely is a responsibility I mean
this is one of our ways that we're going
to conquer this water issue as you heard
mention in there 97% of it is salt
waterer the three remaining percent two
of it locked in ice so we have 1% that's
being used faster than we can refresh
problem with dile though is it's heavy
energy intensive and and by its nature
it's at sea level you're constantly
pumping water uphill Alexandra go ahead
well look I think um desalination should
be a last resort the truth is we have
natural systems in place that provide us
with our water we're plundering those
resources we're destroying those systems
and we're squandering the water we have
our first line of defense should be
efficiency and taking care of those
systems before we resort to desalination
go ahead uh Congressman you have an
opinion on this
one well I think you're getting a pretty
good view of this socialist utopian view
uh most people don't go into an area and
build a home or plant a tree or start a
farm unless there's water there and
where you see areas where they're
they've been populating they'll they'll
resort to things like desalination but
what you'll hear from extreme
environmentalism they're opposed to
desalination plants they're opposed to
fossil fuels they're opposed to nuclear
power they're opposed to anything
Running Out of Time Pam um I I'm more
worried about my farmers in California
than I am outside of this country is
that bad of me the the farmers in
California that is a a heinous that is a
political fraud that ecology is a
political fraud that that whole
Community is being starved by this idea
goes to show you how far how far down
the rabbit hole we've gotten Dr G I'm
sorry Pammy Dr G uh go ahead take me
down my
friend well first of all diesel is going
to be part of our future but it's going
to be very expensive it's never going to
provide water for Farmers because it's
going to be too expensive uh and and the
reality is uh we have a mix of of
sources of water we have
to you're saying too expensive I'm sorry
doct you're saying too expensive we're
talking about shipping water Farm it's
seven times the cost of what you pay
town but uh if you don't have any you'll
pay anything for it all right I'm going
to have to leave it there we have a huge
panel just say goodbye to everyone in
all the boxes it was a fantastic show a
smart show great show thank you to
everyone on the panel see you guys
tomorrow night